welcome back a massive treasure that
dates back about two thousand years it's
hidden deep underground in Italy's
capital city the ancient Roman Basilica
was discovered by accident under a train
station it just opened to the public
inside are more than 20 stucco artworks
fully restored death dome takes us on a
tour of the ancient city that's full of
new surprises trains have rumbled into
Rome's termini station since the
mid-1800s
but long before and deep below these
tracks there was something hidden away
for nearly two millennia 30 feet down is
an underground Basilica which Luca Del
FRA with Rome's Cultural Heritage Bureau
explains was discovered by chance when
digging a hole a hundred years ago put
their head inside this Basilica the
oldest of its kind dates to the era of
Rome's first emperor Augustus the
powerful family that built it one theory
goes was not in favor with later
Emperor's so the structure was filled in
with dirt and abandoned for stores
including Laurel IPPY have been working
to clean the ancient stucco artwork and
uncover clues as to what this might have
been perhaps an ancient tomb or a place
for pagan rites a sudden
animation shows how this basilica was
built around 2,000 years ago
first the spaces for the columns were
excavated and reinforced then the arched
ceiling was formed and the earth removed
from the grand spaces all underground
over the centuries dirt and calcium
carbonate caked over the stucco covering
the ancient figures depicting then
everyday life instruments and shields
[Music]
but that grime also protected it
it seems incredibly difficult to remove
this darker calcium carbonate but not
affect the art and such below that is
the reason why the laser technology was
so important to us we take care of our
sort of surgical way in this city with
layers upon layers of history there are
often spectacular discoveries not all of
them from the ancient world off a
regular Street in a nondescript building
we saw the 2018 restoration of what had
been a store for lamps but revealed this
fantastically colorful and priceless
mural you think of discovering something
in Rome that's thousands of years old
but this was hidden just 100 years of
archeology of the present famed futurist
artist Giacomo Bala painted this in what
had been a 1920s era jazz club called
ball tick-tock Rome is constantly
finding pieces of its past we've
explored a metro station where they've
created a museum with all they've found
some of the subway excavation
discoveries are too big to fit in glass
cases these were the military barracks
of emperor hadrian if you're a restorer
Rome is a good place to work okay stores
archeologists and historians today
working in this ancient city are
constantly learning more about its past
through these unfolding tantalizing
discoveries for CBS this morning Seth
Doane Rome can I just say that stuff
definitely has the best job
that's why you got to go to Rome that's
absolutely have you been yeah step down
and Rome alright well we'll be right
back your local news is next
you